son profil est que si laide que moi
alors aussi alors j'ai aussi l'aide de
la wii au syded oui oui son
jeu le but est de chercher noise a parlé
de sa part les deux miss alors ça
parlait pas du tout de miss depuis le
dette et non le rossy de palma non non
non c'est une actrice alors non c'est
pas non mais alors alors elle est
toujours en vie
vous avez remarqué le juge jean-michel
brigitte bardot l'aide comme des led
led
chez moi alors
allez extrêmement célèbre si je vous dis
à vous aider quand même si je vous dis
mes pièces jaunes
bah oui bernadette chirac paribas et
prom c'est la journaliste catherine née
qui a révélé sa sur europe 1 il aurait
confié que voilà que les maîtresses de
jacques chirac était aussi l'aide à aka
khel parce que ses coups de pied de
l'âne bah oui bah oui c'était un petit
homme connaissait la pirate il était
quand même voilà il était assez car
alors on passe on l'appelait 3000 douche
comprise c'est vrai
quatorze minutes douche compte alors
madame comme pour les plus jeunes qui
m'ont gardé une dame qui avait
déjà fourni beaucoup de bd score de la
première agence s kong et voilà en
france et aux politiques aux acteurs ou
chanteurs à tout le monde et y compris
des gens de ma famille voilà
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous trouverez mais mais mais mais mais
c'est vrai parce que oui moi je vous
raconte pas mais c'est vrai allez on va
passer une nouvelle
secousse mais de la vidéo de jacques
chirac
à ses sympathisants que j ai hâte d'être
à peu émoustillé et on redémarre comme
en
garde irene
côté
[Musique]
à la
mesdames et messieurs les élus mais
chaque collègue isabelle
n'avait pas su si je l'avais plus frais
venu pour cet événement unis
[Rires]
e
pour nous
6 je disais
de fait le poids
et tout nu
son visage la soumission mais maintenant
c'est bernadette là vous voyez caribou
ses collaborateurs et elle n'était plus
sa collaboratrice que ça à son épouse et
quand il a présenté le disait pas je
vous présente mon épouse et je vous
présente ma collaboratrice de m
attention vu vu la vidéo c'est cause
toujours tu m'intéresses qua non voilà
voilà aussi aussi à être qu'on lui
connaît des maîtresses officielle à
jacques chirac maintenant nathalie
laroque ont
déjà de chasse irakiens l'actrice
italienne claudia
avéré quoi oui à beyrède mais c'est pas
office mais j'avais au fond c'est assez
pas grand chose dans l'anonymat il fait
plutôt dans l'anonymat
les expatriés énormément au maroc je
crois donc avant il devait avoir pas mal
de mes très sympa je crois oui mais non
on va avancer
prenez rémy chez ea qu'au départ on
se connaît pas et permet des salaires
dans mieux si la famille en or mieux
également l'achat classés soit au débat
celui des garçons philippe huelin quoi